foreign
[Music]
edition of spectator TV
just over three months ago Liz trust
left 10 Downing Street and since then
she has said nothing
in an article for the Sunday Telegraph
she is detailed what she thinks are
wrong in number 10 and what next for the
conservative party
I'm Katie balls I'm joined by Fraser
Nelson and we bring you Liz truss's
first interview since leaving Downing
Street
thank you for joining spectator TV today
that's great to be here
so I suppose to begin why now
or of course after I left number 10
I needed to take a bit of time to look
at what had happened because I went in
there after a very intense leadership
election in fact after quite an intense
period of foreign secretary as well
we faced a media issues dealing with the
energy crisis there was then the very
sad death of her majesty the queen we
then had the budget and all the
aftermath of that so I wanted to take
some time to look at what happened and
look at what lessons I could learn what
lessons we could learn because clearly I
went into number 10 with a bold agenda I
wanted to change things that's why I put
myself forward to be prime minister
and that didn't work out although there
were some things that we managed to
achieve namely the energy package which
prevented people facing very high bills
that winter and I believe stopped a lot
of businesses going out of business
we also were able to get rid of the
Health and Social care Levy and
eliminate that from our tax system
there were other things that didn't go
so well and so I wanted to take time to
think about it to look at what had
happened and there were particular
issues for example around liability
driven Investments that caused the
markets to be quite tricky so I wanted
to take time to consider that and that's
why I've written the article really
explaining from my point of view what it
felt like at the time why I took the
decisions I took and what we what we now
need to do and I suppose before we get
to uh your time at number 10 you say in
the article that you always would be
crazy to depose a Boris Johnson and it
meant when that did happen and you
didn't feel as though you actually
really had the infrastructure in place
but all of a sudden you didn't see
anyone making the economic argument that
you thought should be being made so you
throw your hat in the ring but as was
given the scale and how much you wanted
to change did it feel then that you were
unprepared all I suppose fighting
against the clock
well it always felt like it was a big
Challenge and since I've been a
government Minister I was a government
Minister for 10 years I've been fighting
some of these battles I didn't support
the rising National Insurance I wanted
to do things like Child Care reform way
back when I was in the education
department and you know there are other
areas that you know we had discussions
about inside government whether those
were trade deals whether it was our
foreign policy I knew there was a battle
to be had
and I also knew that there was a very
very tough situation that we faced as a
country with the war in Ukraine the
energy crisis the aftermath of covert
and
you know I think one of the things I
underestimated was this the sort of
scale of the Orthodoxy so during the
leadership election campaign I talked
about the treasury Orthodoxy I talked
about the fact that we'd ended up in a
situation where we had the highest taxes
for 70 years who had quite big
government uh
so
I believed it was doable but I knew it
would be tough I just probably didn't
realize quite how tough and I just think
after being in
government for 10 years you you then
sort of get into the campaign and it was
a sort of conveyor belt it's like and we
were spending time just thinking how do
we fight this stage of the campaign what
do we need to do now so it's only
afterwards I've been able to look back
and just say that was an incredibly
intense year a lot of people would think
that it's we've given you a prime
minister you can do pretty much under
the British system you've got control of
the government you might not be able to
pass for laws you want but you can
control the system but you see in your
article that um I assumed upon entering
the earnings Street my mandate would be
respected and accepted how wrong I was
what do you mean by that
see what I mean is first of all there
are forces within within the government
itself and The Wider institutional
structure that have a given point of
view you know they have a point of view
which isn't necessarily the point of
view of the elected government and I've
I've seen that you know in every
government Department I've worked in you
know for example the view of brexit uh
bipart of Whitehall or you know the view
of
reform to institutions so I've always
known that there is
there is system resistance and you know
there always is every democracy has
institutions or people who have a
particular point of view that doesn't
agree uh with the elected government and
I also think the political support I had
during the my time in number 10 and it
wasn't enough to achieve the type of
bold reforms I was looking to achieve so
it was a combination if you like of the
economic Orthodoxy which you know for
more than 10 years we've had relatively
cheap money you know low interest rates
relatively High
government spending and you know there's
been a variety of factors that cause
that covert is a good example and
relatively high taxes
and that has but also not diverging from
the EU not doing some of the
deregulatory stuff that might have got
growth going more so those attitudes
were part of the system at the same time
as
okay as I say the the level of political
support required to maybe change some of
these attitudes wasn't there that's
that's what I found and can you give an
example in ways in which you encountered
this resistance it means a little bit
hard to imagine from from the outside
from the outside it seems you can do
what you want but how did this
manifest itself
so
I mean take the take the sort of case in
point the mini budget and the aftermath
of the mini budget so I mean there are
other issues connected with the mini
budget particularly the ldis and what
was happening in the bond market this is
the the Pension funds and the assets
within them yeah
so that was that was a separate issue
which which I can talk about in a minute
if you like but the
so I think it was particularly the issue
around the obr forecast so what the obr
does is it operates independent from
government essentially at arm's lengths
predicting how much
a gap that will be in five years time
for a given Target so getting debt
falling so the obr predicted and the
predictions varied over time between a
50 and a 70 billion pound Gap
what that means as the elected
government if you want to have
credibility you have to show how you'll
fill the gap
so that gives you less room for maneuver
over tax and spending policy than you
might think you have as prime minister
and Chancellor because essentially a
Outside Agency is determining the
envelope you operate in and I think it's
one of the reasons we have put up
corporation tax and why it's quite
difficult to cut in the current
circumstance is because of that
forecasting process isn't it the case
that the government sets the fiscal
rules it sets its own Rule and then the
ubr will say whether you're likely to
meet your rule so in the way the obr
isn't really telling you how much to
borrow or how much you can spend to
Simply say is this government likely to
meet its own test see first of all it
makes assumptions about what policies
are deliverable
or not deliverable so that gives the obr
a certain amount of power over whether
or not particular items will be scored
in the forecast or not I.E whether they
will count
it's also able to assess
how much you know if you raise tax rates
how much revenue will that raise so my
view on corporation tax for example
is Raising it significantly isn't likely
to increase revenues as much as expected
because you can see a reduction in
business investment and reduction
activity
but it's up to the obr what assumptions
they make about that
likewise they make assumptions about
economic growth there's a lot of power
in determining those assumptions
about in terms of what the end result of
the forecast is and therefore what the
government has to aim for
and previously that was all done
in-house in the treasury and I think one
of the other issues isn't just the
forecasting process and the the fact
that it's very difficult to forecast the
future it's very difficult to predict
what's happening five years out but it's
not just that it's also the fact that
the forecasts aren't done alongside of
developing the policy and the treasury
so essentially the forecasting process
has been outsourced and I think that's
also difficult
for ministers who are coming up with
policy because it's a independent
process it doesn't actually constrain
you I'm trying to work out you if you're
saying but the way if you say you
disagree with the obr about the
effective tax cuts you might think that
it'll have more of an effect in the
economy than they do but can you not say
well you know what I disagree with you
I'm doing it anyway the obr and
you know is its position is taken very
seriously by the market
so it effectively
constrains what what the government can
do and by the way I understand
completely while the obr was introduced
you know it's very important that
forecasts are honest but I think we have
ended up in a place where
they're done so independent you know
they're done separately of government
that it ends up driving fiscal policy so
what we've seen is
corporation tax has been increased
as a result of having to fill the hole
of a forecast predicted by the ABR
that's that's that that has become the
reality of the of the system I'm not
saying that we should go back to the old
ways of you know somebody putting their
finger in that the air but I think there
needs to be more discussion around the
assumptions that are being made in the
models a more opportunity for the
government itself to be creating the
forecast
and on deliverability which he mentioned
is that the obr looking at whether they
think the Tory party MPS will back these
measures is that a factor too
well that I mean it's really a question
you should all see ABR rather than me
but it is exactly the sort of question I
think should be able to be asked yeah
you know what are these assumptions
based on
if you're looking at tax cuts that you
think might lead to Grace or supply side
reforms why are those assumptions being
made and my my view and I say this in
the article is that the way the model
Works which is essentially a pretty
static model tends to favor raising
taxes over reducing spending it tends to
favor short-term measures over long-term
measures a lot of the supply side
reforms like you know changing the
planning system or putting in the
investment zones or Child Care reforms
to make Child Care cheaper for working
parents those are all things that take
time to work through and I think the way
that the system works at the moment
mitigates against those types of
measures so
it if you're a government looking at the
you know balancing the books over a
period of time
the tax measures are the you know become
the the ones to do that will actually
deliver on the time scale
now we want to talk about the the mini
budget but I just wondered uh probably
in the in the build up to it when you
were criticized for not going to the obr
ahead of it and you also criticized with
uh axing Tom scholar as permanent
secretary in the treasury
um which I think when things started to
get quite jumpy after the minibus people
said you know those are things that had
added to this sense of speaking the
markets do you regret either of those
decisions
well I mean if we look at the what
happened first of all
as soon as I got into office we had an
immediate issue of energy bills
so people were anticipating energy bills
of up to six thousand pounds that winter
we had a lot of businesses that could
potentially go out of business because
of the scale of the expected energy
price spike and we knew we had to act
before the bills went out in October
otherwise we would have had a very
serious winter crisis that's why the
first thing we did was act on energy
bills and we did that within the first
few days of getting into Downing Street
and that was that was the biggest part
of the mini budget I mean 60 the energy
cost was 60 of the mini budget you might
even call that borrowing spend rather
than tax cuts well what it was was it
was offering a guarantee that if prices
went over a certain level the government
would essentially share the risk with
consumers and with business because
frankly the government have failed to
act 20 years ago to make sure there were
sufficient independent energy supplies
and we'd become dependent on the on the
global market price but I'm very clear
that if we hadn't acted we would have
seen a big drop in business confidence
in real real issues with people not
being able to afford their energy bills
and fearing their energy bills because
you've targeted a bit better I mean you
ended up with millionaires being
subsidized under your system
well the the answer is we did look at
that those types of options but we
couldn't deliver it with the systems the
government had that's
yeah you don't live in a perfect world
we lived in a world of being able to do
something comprehensive that would
reassure businesses and consumers or not
being able to tackle the level that we
had but
I think we've seen since coming up with
a targeted scheme is really difficult
and we didn't necessarily have the
systems at the time to be able to
deliver it in time for October because
that's you know got into government in
September and the bills were arriving in
October
then her majesty the queen sadly died in
fact she died on the day we made the
energy announcement so on the day we
made the energy announcement we promised
because we hadn't given a costing for it
we promised that we'd come back have a
fiscal event and give the costing so
that essentially set the date for the
mini budget which is why we had to act
quickly because otherwise we would have
had the open-ended costing
the markets would have been concerned
that we didn't know what we were
spending
that's why we had to do the mini budget
when we did it when we did it then and
if we left it any longer we would have
had other problems I think it's it's one
of these things in these scenarios that
you never know what the counter factual
looks like
but the counter factual if we hadn't
acted would we went into winter with
people expecting six thousand pound
energy bills and
not reversing the National Insurance
rise which I'd said I would do and it
was a key part of my campaign pledge was
reversing the National Insurance revise
and not raising corporation tax and I
felt that was very important to get the
economy growing
and what I'd said during the leadership
campaign is I wanted to be bold I wanted
to take action in Britain had been had
relatively slow growth for over a decade
and as a country we weren't going to get
on the right trajectory by continuing
with the high levels of tax so that's
that's why I acted I mean the the key
thing we didn't know about was the ldi
issue
and you know although there were issues
with the mini budget and I'm happy to
talk about that
you know what what I've subsequently
discovered is the problems in the bond
market preceded the mini budget you see
in your article that you were shocked to
discover the size of the problem of
these liability driven Investments ldis
that the assets were something like 60
of GDP and that this was new language
what a delegate Tinderbox you were
dealing with
um now if our Pension funds were so
sensitive to um changes in interest
rates and if this was a Tinderbox as you
say is it something that you wish should
be warned about earlier on and if you
had known how big a cell incentive an
issue would have changed how you
approached the budget
so the the answer is yes we would have
done things differently
if we'd known about this issue
because the day before the mini budget
you know it's always the announcement by
the bank of England about interest rates
there's also an announcement about bonds
and there were ready movements in the
bond market what we didn't understand is
the fragility caused by these
liability-driven Investments and
essentially
what it meant was that small movements
or movements rapid movements in the
market could result in cash calls
happening and you know essentially a
chain reaction that's what we didn't
understand and if if we'd known that
beforehand we certainly would have you
know maybe moved the mini budget or
waited a few days to see what happened
it was the it was the Confluence of
those different events I think that made
it particularly difficult and that's why
you know on the Monday the governor of
the bank of England intervened
specifically on the ldi issue probably
the should have been better
communication as well I mean it's but it
was something I simply did not know
about I didn't know the existence of
ldis which turned out to be the main
problem
uh the following week do you think
somebody should have
um flagged this up as such a big issue
mentioning the bank of England which is
I guess in charge of regulating this
could have said look interest rates are
going up world over Britain's rather
uniquely exposed because of the nature
of our final salary pension schemes and
the way that these ldi's respond to the
the bond rates I mean did you feel that
you were basically not briefed and as a
result of not being briefed properly you
made decisions which you otherwise not
have made I mean of course this is
really a matter for the chancellor
rather than the Prime Minister but my
understanding is he wasn't informed of
this either and I do think it's
something that should have been better
understood and communicated as I said we
were being driven by
the urgency of sorting out the situation
with the energy markets and making sure
we implemented our tax pledges so that
they could start having a positive
impact on the economy because we were
very concerned about a potential
recession we were very concerned about
the cost of energy so that was our
driving Factor
and
our assumption was that we'd worked up
these plans with treasury officials that
if there had been a major problem it
would have been it would have been
flagged to us yes but as I said I think
the specific point you've made Fraser
that's for that's for others to answer
who know more about the financial
regulatory system
uh rather than
rather than me and my role
in your article you see it was the ldis
that brought your Premiership to an
abrupt and premature end well I think
that was the it was the fragility of the
market I'm not by the way saying that I
got everything right you know absolutely
not uh
the communication wasn't good enough
I didn't have good enough infrastructure
the whole the whole process of the you
know going straight from being foreign
secretary at what was an extremely
extremely busy time through the
leadership campaign into number 10. you
wasn't ideal for the level of
preparation infrastructure building that
we needed to do but but what I'm saying
is that
I think without that ldi issue things
might well have been different and
knowing about it would have been helpful
yeah I suppose
um when you think about the treasury
removing a long-standing permanent
secretary he might have some of that
institutional knowledge means that
perhaps there's you're making it harder
to or you're reducing some of the
opportunities to to get some of that or
increasing the market Jitters that you
refer to in your article
I mean I think it's important that
you know the chancellor or other
government ministers are able to
make sure they've got the officials
around them that they feel will support
the policies that they are or you know
put in place the measures that's what
impossibly I'm sure we're not saying
there's only one person at the treasury
who knows who knows what's going on that
doesn't seem uh that doesn't seem
credible to me and
a
the issue and and I point to this in the
article I'm not accusing any individual
of you know being deliberately difficult
or anything like that what I'm saying is
there has been an overall approach
on British economic policy for the past
15 years that is an Orthodoxy and we
were actively seeking to challenge that
Orthodoxy and I explicitly said that
during the leadership campaign and I
think one of the things I didn't realize
is just how strongly Orthodoxy was and
how embedded around the system it was so
you know on the point about
communication yes you know we should
have had better communication but we
were in essence relying on a system who
didn't necessarily share our approach
that and that is a difficult position to
be in it wasn't just in Britain though
you had the IMF you even know Joe Biden
passing comments on new policies was it
surprised to get that level of
international commentary well
particularly as the IMF now seemed to
have taken the reverse position and say
we should have cut taxes whereas they
said we shouldn't cut taxes back uh back
in the Autumn but I think it reflects a
drift right across the Free World
towards what are essentially more
socially Democratic policies you know
higher taxes higher spending bigger
government
relatively low interest rates and cheap
money and
that
it's no doubt that those of us on the
side of politics who believe in
smaller government
free markets you have not been winning
the argument I mean that's the other
thing I would say alongside the specific
issues around the ldis alongside
the
you know the communications issues we
had there is also
the weather's changed
the weather's changed and it what I
found was trying to make those arguments
that low taxes are a good thing that
they'll help attract investment into
Britain that that will drive economic
growth that economic growth will benefit
everybody
those arguments didn't fall on
particularly fertile ground including in
your own party including in my own party
but I think you know broadly across the
media the arguments that we might have
made 20 years ago that were taken for
granted and no longer
are no longer readily readily believed
were you surprised that the president of
the United States specifically
criticized your tax policy I was yes
what were you doing when you found out
I it was quite a busy time Katie so I
can't remember
exactly what I was doing but
the
we'd been through the very difficult
death of her majesty the queen and the
funeral I'd actually been over and met
present Biden at the UN
and we were then dealing with the issues
of energy but also dealing with very
serious security issues Russian saber
rattling so I didn't really have time to
sort of
cool present Biden or get concerned
about his comments because we need to do
we needed to deliver in what was a very
difficult situation and just on the mini
budget before I think obviously we move
on from that there was just two things I
wanted which was the first is I mean
you've served under three different
Prime Ministers
um you know how much events can take
over uh you know people's agendas have
to go to one side so did you feel that
you think about the number of measures
you put in did you feel as though you
needed to do everything quite quickly
because you only had you know 18 months
two years to the next election was that
was that a factor when you're deciding
what to put in it
well I think I think it's worth pointing
out that the vast majority of the mini
budget was the energy package plus the
two measures that I denounced during the
leadership campaign reversing National
Insurance
and keeping corporation tax low and a
lot of people refer to unfunded tax cuts
what we were talking about is not
raising taxes that's what we were by and
large talking about and the other
measures were fairly small in the
general in the general scheme of things
so the vast bulk of the mini budget were
things that had already been that
already been heavily trailed one of the
most politically huge and that was the
45p tax I mean relatively small on the
size and the cost of your budget but
when it comes to political issues it's
absolutely enormous isn't it
well so so it proved Fraser so it so it
proved I mean the way the way we looked
at it is we wanted to be as clear as
possible that Britain was open for
business we wanted to attract investment
we all wanted to attract people to the
United Kingdom we want to attract
business and we also wanted to
make sure that everybody right across
the income scale you know had the
opportunity had the incentive to to work
and to to participate in the economy I
mean that's the that's why we did it I
think economically it was absolutely the
right thing to do I appreciate what you
say about the politics and perhaps I
underestimated the political the
political impact it had but you know
it's back to what Katie was saying
okay
I was very very worried about the
economic position of the United Kingdom
we were very concerned about energy
costs but also about an impending
recession
and we needed to share we were
delivering which is why things like the
investment zones we wanted to get on
with those straight away so that people
would start seeing the Spades and the
ground see their local communities
changing see things happening that's why
we wanted to do it last Autumn so that
because these things take time and I'm
aware of it you know tax cuts take time
to come through business investment
decisions you know once you've announced
your corporation tax policy it takes a
while before companies make the
investment decision to locate in the UK
so it was why it was important to do it
fairly early on for precisely those
reasons for the reasons you just laid
out do you regret putting the 45p rate
in that many budget
well I mean
we could all think different things with
hindsight and perhaps
perhaps it was a it was a bridge too far
but I'm not convinced that it was a sort
of Magic Bullet that everything would
have been fine
if we hadn't done that because
you know I thought it was quite
significant that
after there were more Market wobbles and
we reversed the 45p tax
decision relatively soon we were
essentially forced to reverse the
position on corporation tax so although
you know maybe it was a step too far I
you know who knows we can all you know
you could all do different this is my
point about counter factuals you know
it's uh it's easy to say
um I still believe it's the right I
still believe it's the right thing to do
for Britain during the vast majority of
Labor government we had a 40p top tax
rate the problem is though that it goes
back to the point about why have we not
won the argument for the past 10 years
about keeping taxes low
giving people more control of their own
money
cutting business regulation
why have we not won these arguments
because we have tried to placate you
know a lot of the
the distributionists and those are
people in Britain who think
the pie isn't going to get any bigger
the only economic debate is about how we
divide it between
different people I fundamentally don't
agree with that I think if you have
lower taxes right across the board the
country becomes more successful and that
benefits everybody and I think that's
the argument we fundamentally haven't
won it was I trying to fatten the pig on
Market day maybe you know there's a long
history of failing to make the case and
you know that's that's what I'm thinking
now I'm thinking how can how can we make
that argument because it certainly isn't
going to make our country successful in
the long term having ever higher taxes
always having the argument that you
can't cut the it's never a good time to
cut the top rate of tax is the reality
you know
and then I mean after the mini budget
and we've spoken about now the reasons
obviously it went wrong for vet for
various uh factors but it feels at that
point that's when the premise really
takes a turn you get to Tory conference
I'm not sure um how you would describe
your Tory conference
um so I think
to look the most um well you never do I
mean the thing about doing the job is
you never know what it looks like from
the outside because you're consumed by
you know doing uh doing what you have to
do I think it was very difficult it was
very difficult when we had to probably
the week after the conference when we
had to reverse elements of the mini
budget and then
I was in a position of rather than
pursuing my policy agenda
trying to avoid
a serious Market meltdown which is why
I had to do what I had to do but yes I
think
you know after
we had to make those changes it was a it
was a very difficult position I was in
perhaps the biggest change you made was
um losing quasi-quartering one of your
most longest standing political allies
there must have been a very difficult
decision it was very difficult it was
very difficult and
a reversing reversing the measures in
the mini budget as well that we thought
were right was very difficult if achieve
you didn't disagree in anything did you
and as far as I can work out no yeah he
still had to go
see you know I'm
I can't I can't say it was anything but
extremely difficult but
he was in Washington at the time at the
um IMF meeting
and you know I was getting some very
serious warnings from senior officials
that the you know there could be a
potential Market meltdown
the following week if I didn't take
action and
I needed to do as much as I could
to indicate that things were different
and that's why I took the decision I did
and I I weighed it up you know I weighed
up in my mind about whether I needed to
do that but the reality was I couldn't
in all conscience
they risk risk that situation in terms
of what you're hearing will happen in
the economy
but did you did you think then that this
at what point did you think well my
Premiership is probably over I might be
playing for time now but it's because if
your Chancellor was doing what you asked
him when he goes doesn't your Authority
go with it well yes and I think that was
probably the case
just in terms of so obviously looking
back from where we're sitting now I can
see that
at the time I was just thinking how do I
make sure there's not a market meltdown
so I wasn't really
focused on my long-term future I was
focused on making sure
the country wasn't in a serious
situation and I mean we've can talk a
lot about the criticism you know
um lettuces etc etc all the time but
what was it like at that point I mean
what personal toll was it taking on you
[Music]
um
it was tough it was absolutely tough but
I think when you're in those types of
situation you just have to focus on what
needs to be done so and I am a focused
person so if I sort of
just got on with it got on with it and
you know I went in with a very clear
agenda about what we needed to deliver
all kinds of events took place uh which
I wasn't expecting and quasi wasn't
expecting frankly and we had to deal
with the Fallout of that and I think one
of the
one of the issues was because we were so
new in government dealing with the
Fallout or something like the ldi crisis
that we didn't know about was very
difficult so people said well why aren't
you communicating with the fact is we
didn't know about the issue we didn't
necessarily understand the issue and
that is a difficult position to be in as
as as pm and Chancellor I think by the
end of the period
now I wanted to make sure
that the markets were stable
you know because
at my heart I'm a patriot I didn't want
you know I want Britain to be successful
I certainly don't want us to get in a
position where there is a meltdown and
so that was that was my focus and if you
say what what personal toll did it take
on me
I mean it was tough but it was
you know I just got on with it and I
suppose it's a final thing on on losing
your chance there I mean there are
reports at the time he found out on
Twitter on the way to meet you
um and then I mean other pair of you
given you have you know you've written
books a book together in the past week
are you are you back on you know uh
friendly terms
like I I count quasi as a friend and you
know what what happened
wasn't you know it was a difficult
decision and I
if was it the right decision
is very hard to it's very hard to tell
but I had to make sure I was doing
everything to to to deal with a very
serious situation we're in but I have to
get up on you see you went in a matter
of days and thinking okay I've got these
forces of um
conservatism shall we see a small sea
against me I'm going to overcome them
I'm going to make the radical arguments
I mean are they might not agree with me
but somebody needs to break the
Deadlocks you're in that mindset in the
in the mini budget indirectly afterwards
um I remember meeting quasi um on the
evening and he was saying that the
markets are wobbling but they'll come
down eventually and you can see you can
see the argument for that but that
switched pretty quickly from that to
people telling you look prime minister
this is really serious you're gonna face
a meltdown you're going to lose your
Chancellor
and she would have gone from first of
thinking well I'm going to prove these
guys wrong to thinking actually I better
do what they say
yes
that's a good summary of the situation
it's a good it's a good summary of the
situation and
as I say if um
if we known about things we could have
prepared better but
I don't think we could have delayed
putting the measures in I think that's
an important point to make just because
of the very serious economic situation
we were in visibly the energy process
and you say that perhaps it was a moment
you lost your chance that you realized
you know you could perhaps see the
writing on the wall when you decided to
step down
um I think Graham Brady the chair of the
1922 has praised you for of the of all
the various conversations he's had in
recent times with prime ministers on the
way out
um someone who did not fight it as some
of the predecessors did but the night
before there was a you know a very messy
Commons vote
um on fracking at what point did you
think actually you know I tried I've
been trying to keep the show on the
roads as best if I stepped down was it
that evening
I think it had been uh sort of
I was becoming more aware of just how
difficult it was I think
one side
appointed the new Chancellor and we'd
had to change the policies which was a
reaction to
the market pressure as you say
I thought at that point it was difficult
for me to continue for much because I'd
my whole campaign the whole reason I
stood for the leadership was to pursue a
different economic policy that was my
motivation
I mean that was you know that was my
motivation for getting involved in
politics in the first place so I think
past that it was quite difficult but
I didn't want to sort of drop the ball
or leave leave anybody in the lurch
you talk quite a lot about the apparatus
I guess you're referring to your
personal apparatus around you but when
it comes to trying to making winning the
arguments for for low tax for the growth
agenda and one of the themes of your
articles is that the that the the
progress side if you want to call it
that doesn't have the apparatus you see
even the resistance aside the
conservative party to move to a lower
tax less regulated economy is pretty
significant now if a conservative party
doesn't believe in lower tax and low
regulation if a conservative party
effectively weren't on your side
pretty big problem winning this
arguments
I mean it's always been the case that
the conservative party has been a broad
church and we've always had this debate
it's not a new it's not a new discussion
within the conservative party
but I do think that if you look at the
arguments that led up to the Thatcher
government if you look at the you know
the think tanks that were established
the intellectual movement the sort of
hayax the Friedman's all of that
was part more part of the public
Consciousness it was more part of the so
it's not
it's not the conservative party per se
it's where we are in the Battle of ideas
and
I think that is where we have lost
ground if you look at opinion polling
people are more in favor of higher taxes
now than they were in 2010.
I think covid has had a big impact on
the role of government
I think people expect government to do
more
I think there's an expectation that
government will step in in a way that
wasn't before and of course if you're
like me if you believe that people
should be free to live their lives that
you don't like government telling them
what to do then that is a difficult a
difficult position to be in and I think
the conservative party is a reflection
I mean it's a it's a two-way discussion
but the conservative party the media
the sort of broader
sort of public sphere
a do you think is not moved in a in a
free market direction is that something
which you can
maybe help change now
well I want to help change it absolutely
and look there are people there are
people who do who do agree and you know
I've had a lot of people get in touch
with me saying it's a varying idea
varying degrees
what what you were doing you were trying
to do the right thing so I think there
is
there are people who support this
understand this
but we need to be better at making the
argument we need to think about making
the argument obviously I've got more
time available now to think about these
things and and make the arguments and
that's what I want to do there will also
be some people who will be listening
watching this and saying well actually
look look at the way your Premiership
ended Dicker um the the market turmoil
um you know perhaps those people had to
renew their mortgages at that time and
yes there were Global factors
um and they were saying well are you the
right person to be making the case for
growth and I wonder what would you say
to them well first of all on the
mortgage point I do want to address this
because
the we've been living in a very low
interest rate world and mortgage rates
have been going up and the reason there
was a specific issue around
the time we're talking about in
September a lot of it is to do with the
liability driven Investments and the
impact they had on the market so I don't
think it's fair to blame
you know interest rate Rises on on on
what we did I think that's unfair the
bank of England said it was a 50 50 mix
I think they showed a graph seeing how
that was global factor as half of it was
UK factors I mean would you think that's
well I'm not saying that on the UK
factors I don't believe
I believe there are other UK factors
apart from so they were doing more about
the pension issues in the world well I'm
just saying that that yeah that is
definitely an issue and of course we are
seeing mortgage rates go up
the only question about
nobody would be more delighted than me
Katie if there were lots of other people
coming forward of making these arguments
I would be more than delighted to have
other people go out there and make the
case
but the fact is there aren't enough
people making the case full stop
and
I believe that
I've learned a lot in my time in
government I understand what some of the
pitfalls are I've been through the mill
on this
and
we do need to do things differently and
we need to look at how we do things
because
whatever people's critique might be of
my time in government
the fact is we have had relatively low
economic growth
for
over a decade
and that has a direct impact on
everybody in Britain it has an impact on
people of all incomes
and the you know if you look at GDP per
capita we are falling behind other
countries so there's no doubt there's a
problem
and what the solution isn't is the
solution isn't in my view putting up
taxes or restricting business more than
the the solution has to be about Britain
growing faster and becoming more
competitive but if there are other
people that want to
you know put that case across great but
didn't your Premiership prove a deficit
Finance tax cuts are not the answer
isn't that the moral of this trust
Premiership
well I I don't agree that with your the
premise of your question because
what we were talking about on
corporation tax is not raising
corporation tax the problem is that
because we don't have in my view
sufficiently Dynamic forecasting the
prediction was that that would cost
money and it was the direct relationship
of the ABR forecast with the market
that's the issue and the prevailing
Orthodoxy which is that raising taxes
increases Revenue
that's what in my view that's what the
problem is I mean we already have a
deficit we already have a deficit we
already have a big debt the question is
is the best way to deal with that debt
cutting taxes increasing growth or is
the best way of dealing with that debt
raising taxes now my view is raising
taxes as a counterproductive is not
actually going to lead to reducing debt
in five years time
but that my view is not shared by this
broader Orthodoxy that's that's the
issue you mentioned this new article
about the corporation text but just to
be clear are you saying you don't think
that that's basically abandoning the
corporation tax Rises and The obr said
that would cost a certain amount of
money are you seeing the exaggerated how
much it would cost or are you saying
that you believe that if taxes are being
kept low that would have created so much
growth that would have actually
generated more money than what you might
theoretically a government tax rights
those are both the same points which is
the the forecasting is not Dynamic
enough about the impact of keeping
corporation tax low that essentially
the forecasting process undervalues
measures that drive economic growth
and it overvalues raising taxes as a way
of generating Revenue because it doesn't
take into account the long-term impact
of having big government more regulation
high taxes which ultimately slows growth
in our economy and we can see from
what's happened over the past decade or
so
that you know we've got the highest rate
of taxes now for 70 years and we can see
what the projected levels of growth are
so people have got to answer a question
why
why is there such low growth in your
article as logistic include this
interview
you talk about how your husband
ultimately told you this is going to be
an awful it's a very wise campaign he's
a bit of a soothsayer yeah as a psychic
career perhaps away
um
do you feel better at forecasting a lot
of people
do you regret going for prime minister
no
I don't I don't regret it and would you
want to be prime minister again no
are you I thought you were never
scenario sort of person
I think
I'm definitely
promoting a pro-grace agenda you know I
definitely want to carry on as a MP
I'm
you know I'm positive about the future
of Britain I'm positive about the future
of the conservative party I think we
need to start building more of a you
know a strong intellectual base
but I'm not uh desperate to get back
into number 10 now
anniversary soon act you'll be
supporting him I will be supporting him
thank you Liz trust for your time today
thank you
[Music]
foreign